-Guys, I know a lot of
people find math boring.
Well, that's why
we've updated math
to make equations be about
stuff that you can relate to.
It's time for
"Popular Mathematics."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Popular ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
-Let's take a look at
our first equation here.
If you take a check mark
plus a dad bod,
it equals the Nike logo.
See what I'm saying?
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, then if you take a
streaming service
plus the movie
"Gone in 60 Seconds,"
it equals CNN+.
It makes you like math again.
Here's another one.
Mexican culture
plus Italian culture
plus a middle finger
equals Taco Bell's
Mexican pizza.
I'm still going to try it.
I'm still going to try it and
I'll probably like it.
If you take an old-school camera
plus shooting
the whole roll of film
plus forgetting to take off
the lens cap,
it equals Kodak Black.
You understand?
And, finally,
if you take positive vibes
plus positive COVID test,
it equals Coachella.
There you go.
That's all the time we have for
"Popular Mathematics."